من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللي عم يتحنى مرحبا بك ما
المقصود باعاده ضبط استراتيجيه كياف
العسكريه
جلال اشتهرت اوكرانيا
بسريه عاليه تجاه المعلومات والعمليات
العسكريه خاصه مع الامريكيين اليوم بعد
تعثر هذا الهجوم هناك خلاف في الرؤيه
الاستراتيجيه يعني الرؤيه الامريكيه تقول
دربنا سبعه سبعين الف جندي
جهزنا واعطينا ما يلزم يجب ان يتم التركيز
على محور واحد فقط الخرق منه وبالتالي
الوصول الى تقريبا حدود شبه جزيره قرن
وبالتحديد في زفروجيا بينما الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه
يعني الحرب على عده مواقع على 900 كلم خط
الاشتباك ومنها على سبيل المثال بخموت
نوفوسيلكا واوريكيب لا يجب التركيز على خط
واحد من هنا الاجتماع على الحدود
الاوكرانيه البولنديه مع اهم مسؤولي
عسكريين وحتى القائد العسكري لحلف النت
وكافولي كريستوفر كابولي اجتمع مع هذه
المجموعه وبالتالي بدانا نرى تغيير
بالاستراتيجيه يعني معركه روبوتين والسعي
تجاهك وبالتالي الى مليتو بول ولكن ليست
الامر مهمه وليست نزهه جلال وكان هذا
الاجتماع عميد الياس حنا هو اعتراف ضمني
بما صدر عنه بان الهجوم المضاد في المرحله
الماضيه لم يحقق النتائج المرجوه هل في
اعاده ضبط الاستراتيجيه يمكن تغيير
النتيجه المتوخه وهل اوكرانيا اصلا موافقه
على هذا التغيير واعاده الضبط
اوكرانيا ال سي ترتبط لوجستيا وعسكريا
وسياسيا ومليا بالغرب من الضروري ان
يكونوا هناك القدره على الضغط عليها اليوم
يريد الامريكيون التجربه الكبرى لشيء اعطي
من تدريب وعسكر
واليات ودائما الخوف من العام 2024 الحرب
طويله ماذا لو توقف هذا هذه اللوجستيه
ماذا لو حدث اي تغيير سياسي في مكان ما
اعتقد اليوم هو الذهاب الى خرق معين نصر
معين لالزام بوتين او روسيا للوصول الى
طاوله التفاوض ولا يحدث هذا الامر الا اذا
حدث عبر قطع الجسر البري باتجاه شبه جزيره
القرن طب المفهوم بالمفهوم العسكري العميد
الياس حنا التركيز على جبهه واحده وهي
زبالوجيا الا تستطيع روسيا ايضا ان تركز
دفاعاتها ايضا على هذه الجبهه بدل ان تكون
مشغوله
بجبهات عده من الشرق وصولا الى الجنوب
هذه هي فكره الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه التي
تقول انه يجب ان نوسع نطاق العمليات كي
نثبت الجيش الروسي على جبهه طويله كي لا
يجتمع ولكن جلال اليوم الجيش الروسي يقاتل
بالخطوط الخارجيه ولا يقاتل بالخطوط
الداخليه ما المقصود بهذا الامر هذا القوس
الذي يقاتل عليه الجيش الروسي من الصعوبه
نقل القوات العسكريه من مكان الى اخر
بينما الجيش الاوكراني يقاتل في خطوط
الداخليه والقدره على التحرك ضمن هذه
الدائره هذه هي الفوارق الاساسيه اليوم
اذا فاجات الجيش الروسي في مكان ما خرجت
الدفاع وناورت في الخلفيه قد يكون هناك ما
يسمى بالدومينو افكت طيب كيف يتوقع ان
تتعامل روسيا مع هذا الاجتماع
يعني الواضح جدا بين الناتو واوكرانيا وهي
التي طالما حذرت من ان
يعني حذرت من هذا التدخل الغربي بشكل واضح
وسافر في هذه الحرب
الاوراق مفتوحه على الطاوله منذ فتره منذ
بدايه الحرب قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
نريد ان تكون روسيه ضعيفه وهذا الامر هو
استمرار للسياسه الكبرى ولكن عدم الدخول
في صراع مباشر مع روسيا عدم تسليم
اوكرانيا سلاح يضرب الاراضي الروسيه او
الداخل الروسيه من هنا مارك ميلي لا يزور
حاليا كيف بينما طوني ردكين وهو رئيس
الاركان الانجليزي وهو كان في الاجتماع
يزور من وقت الى اخر رئيس زيلينسكي لاخذ
منه لاخذ منه فعلا ما هي الاستراتيجيه
المستقبليه اليوم الحرب مفتوحه وهي حرب
الواسطه وبامتياز شكرا للعميد الياس حنا
في بيروت